i
[Música]
a
durante la pandemia las cifras de
pobreza en brasil se han triplicado hoy
hay cerca de 27 millones de personas que
viven con menos de un dólar y medio por
día además 19 millones de personas están
pasando hambre y está tan solo siete
años después de que brasil consigue por
fin salir del mapa de la pobreza de la
fao a lo largo de 2020 el gobierno de
brasil entregó un subsidio especial a 68
millones de personas por el valor de 105
dólares por mes sin embargo en diciembre
el subsidio a cabo y el nivel de pobreza
empeoró sensiblemente por esta razón
ahora en abril el gobierno recupera este
subsidio pero va a ser menos dinero 44
dólares por mes y alcanzará menos
familias se calcula que son cerca de 45
millones de personas con la pandemia
fuera de control y cada vez más
desempleo la perspectiva es que in
brazil los índices de pobreza empeoren
[Música]
según los datos oficiales más recientes
del segundo semestre del 2020 el 42% de
los argentinos está por debajo de la
línea de la pobreza un año antes la
pobreza se encontraba en el 35 5% la
principal causa de este incremento está
en la pandemia de kobe 19 en este
contexto el país no logra detener una
alta inflación lo que mina el poder de
compra de los ingresos de la población y
a eso se suman relativamente bajos
niveles de actividad lo que reduce la
posibilidad de generar esos ingresos en
un primer lugar existen al genera una
situación de pobreza estructural además
que precede a la llegada del cob y 19 y
sobre cómo revertirlo existen posiciones
diversas algunos aseguran que la clave
está en la reactivación de la inversión
el incremento de la productividad y el
control de la inflación otros consideran
que se debe aumentar la asistencia
estatal e incrementar los impuestos y
suspender el pago de la deuda soberana
por lo pronto en 2020 para intentar
paliar los efectos de la pandemia el
gobierno implementó programas de
asistencia extraordinaria que aún no se
han repetido en 2021
[Música]
y paraguay un millón novecientos veinte
mil personas viven en la pobreza esto
representa el 26 9% de la población
según cifras difundidas por el gobierno
recientemente los efectos en las
pandemias son bastante claros 2019 2020
o un aumento del 3.4 por ciento de la
pobreza un fenómeno inédito para este
país en la última década la llegada al
coronavirus se tradujo en 264 mil nuevos
pobres que es el pobre en paraguay el
instituto nacional de estadística lo
define como no poder garantizar una
alimentación básica ni tener servicios
considerados esenciales como agua
potable o energía eléctrica
todas estas cifras dieron pie a nuevas
críticas al modelo económico paraguayo
debido a que a pesar de tener una
macroeconomía estable y una que ella
encima del producto interno bruto este
país que produce alimentos para más de
70 millones de personas en el mundo no
es capaz de garantizar un plato de
comida y una vida digna a casi 2
millones de sus habitantes
[Música]